foreign
Melissa is with us in Portland Oregon hi
Melissa welcome to the Ramsay show
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
I discovered your program three years
ago and since then we have paid off my
husband and I 120 000 in debt and I
proudly drive a 2006 Honda Odyssey now
we have
um no debt other than our student loans
and our house but unfortunately
um I guess unfortunately my husband has
a private undergrad a master's degree
and a separate law degree how much is
that debt
we still have a hundred and ninety
thousand dollars in student loan debt
okay yeah and so I'm glad you're on Jade
too because I know you have a similar
experience so yeah well the student loan
debt yes yeah so what's your household
income we have about a three hundred
thousand dollar household income that's
good so we have a big shovel big hole as
you say
um but about half of our income is
um from I own a business I'm
self-employed so it's a little bit more
precarious I would say my husband's um
an attorney and is a little more stable
maybe so how can we decide
yeah so our other
um numbers to share because I know Dave
will ask because I listen all the time
we have about 20 000 in liquid
um savings I'd like to have a little bit
more even though we're gazelle intents
just because I am self-employed I have a
one-year-old and a four-year-old and I
have three to six months no if they
still have a hundred ninety thousand
dollars in debt we still have 190 000 so
oh I see I see yeah yeah that but
because I'm self-employed
um okay so what's your question okay so
my question is we living in pretty
somewhat unsafe area without great
schools and my oldest son is going to be
in kindergarten next year and so we are
hoping to move in a year we have about
two hundred thousand dollars equity in
our house right now and I am but we've
still been just paying the student loan
debt um
the house is probably worth about five
hundred thousand
sounds like a rough neighborhood
half million dollar homes I live in I
live in Portland Oregon so the housing
prices are very high
um no they don't have they don't have
300 000 slums in Portland Oregon 500 000
slimes
yeah I don't have them I've been there
yeah yeah
so my question is should
well Melissa I can take you and show you
some real rough neighborhoods there's
some real ones some real ones yeah yeah
it's just that my my I was hoping that
my son would not have to move schools
okay here's what I would do here's what
I here's what I did
I sold my home
and I rented
okay and I changed my kids schools we
had our kids in private school because
we were in a neighborhood where we
didn't like the schools
um nowhere nowhere near as long long a
lot longer ago than now but nowhere near
the same numbers you're dealing with
um and we sold the house and got it got
dumped the private school tuition and
rented for two years while we got
ourselves straightened up and got out of
debt and then we bought
that's what you should do you should
sell your house take the 200 000 pay off
your student loans
so I we were very close to doing that
last year and I to do that exactly take
the equity and pay off the student loans
which we could do but our mortgage right
now is only 1600. well I sound like I'm
gonna argue with you
no I'm just wondering if the rents are a
lot more expensive you're not going to
have a mortgage you're not going to have
a mortgage you do what you want to do
Melissa okay you do whatever you want to
do
I just told you what we think you should
do you should sell your house and you
should rent if you want to put the kid
in the school pay off your debts take
your fabulous 300 000 income and start
saving up for a down payment rents are
not you know you you have to get
fatalistic on me every time we talk
about it you have the horrible ghetto
that you live in that's a half million
dollar home that's ridiculous statement
then you have rents are so high that
it's impossible to rent well if you
can't afford to rent in the school
district your kids going to go to you
can't afford to buy in the school
district your kids going to go to so we
have a bit of a problem here Melissa
you're going to have to decide which of
these things you want to do you can't
have it all you've tried to have it all
and made your life into a freaking mess
you've got hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of debt never saying no to
you guys
so now it's time to say no
stop it stop doing it so either sit
there
and pay off your student loan debts
starting today like wild people or move
and rent and use the equity to pay it
off you do whatever you want to do
that's what I would do I issue with this
I feel like this is kind of a trend
right now where folks are calling in and
they've said I want that I want to be a
stay-at-home mom and I want to live in
the best school districts and I want
Jimmy to have the best possible and it's
like but if you can't afford it you've
got it it's got to make sense it's got
to make sense in in the span of your
reality and sometimes you have the
opportunity to make it make sense if
you're willing to sacrifice but you
can't have it all without willing to
sacrifice that's important I wanted we
wanted to stop this private school
tuition in the case of the example I
just gave and we wanted to get rid of
the IRS after bankruptcy because the IRS
never goes away right we're one of those
people out of our life and we want the
kids in a school system
we also wanted to own a house
but we one of those other things more
than owning a house and if you ask
Sharon Ramsey to this day that was
um
gosh it's almost 30 years 25 years ago
okay to this day she can describe the
color
of the kitchen floor in the rental she
hated that house I feel that the hate
that I mean and she can describe all the
things that were wrong with that rental
house that that period of our life was
we made choices about what was most
important the things that were less
important were highly unpleasant yeah I
feel that and you've got to do the
unpleasant to get to do the pleasant you
can't just have it all at once it
doesn't work that way to your point
there is a limit on math unless you go
unless you're in Congress other than
that the rest of us have to live within
within finite dollar amounts that's
right and and we have to deal with the
facts and this arithmetic thing it'll
kick your butt it will